Okay.
In seven 43 Oh,
civil war started among,
within the [inaudible] had family over,
uh,
the Khalif for succession.
This war broke out in Persia,
which is a little unusual
because until this point,
the subversive discontented prodo
Shiite region had been what,
uh,
is called Kufa Kuf a basically
southern Iraq as an owl is,
uh,
it's thought that this revolt against
the Umayyads had the support of the
[inaudible] and it makes sense
that if it was in Persia,
the largest non Arab Muslim country,
it makes sense that you would have the
most concentration of non Arab Muslims.
That is to say converts or the descendants
of converts who might feel that the
egalitarian promises of
Islam had been betrayed.
And that in fact the, uh,
religion was an Arab, uh,
one in which non Arabs were
in a subordinate position.
The non Arab Muslims of Persia had
converted some from Christianity.
Most from Zoroastrianism, a, uh, uh,
religion of Central Asia,
uh,
Wickham takes issue with this. Uh, if
you go back to your reading pages to 92,
to two 94, he says, um, uh, that,
uh, he doesn't think that, uh,
the discontent was related to somehow
the Omi is being an excessively Arab
rather than Muslim dynasty. Um, uh,
or that they provoke discontent
among recent converts.
So this is an open question.
I think there's gotta be
some Awali a discontent.
But as we've seen already,
there's plenty of discontent.
Shiite Sunni being the most obvious
intertribal regional problems of holding
this empire together at any way rate.
Um,
uh, the, uh, um, uh,
in seven 49, seven 50, uh,
the [inaudible] had Colloff was deposed
by a member of another family known as
the Abbasids.
This new column,
a boy out about us.
I boss the,
the opposites,
the opposites.
We're early followers of Mohammed,
although not particularly heroic ones.
Oh, I'm the family had been supporters
but hadn't taken very many risks.
So the Bostons or not eeros though,
they were an old family.
Okay.
The Abbasids came to power
with support from the Shiites.
This is what Wickham means by what
he calls their salvationist theology.
Salvationist meaning that they were,
uh,
going to restore the religious fervor
that the Umayyads had dissipated so that
they were originally supposed
to represent a return.
I reformation of Islam too.
It's austere routes in which the college
was a modest clean living austere
figure. They very quickly, if
that was the hope of the Shiites,
the opposite is very, very
quickly to trade this. They,
um,
they moved their capital from Damascus,
the Umayyad capital to a new city
that they constructed in the desert.
Baghdad.
A city built in concentric circles
as a planned round fortress city,
but also commercial city and of course
predominantly city of administration.
It was located 30 miles from
the old Persian capitol.
Persian empire
was ruled from Tessa Fon.
Relocating the capital of the caliphate
to Baghdad has a number of obvious
implications.
While most historians would not be
quite as confident as Peter Brown,
whom you're reading for Wednesday,
is that this represents the
Persian ization of the caliphate.
It is certainly true that moving
the Capitol to modern Iran, uh,
modern Iraq to the Mesopotamian part of
the former Persian empire orients the
califate further to the east.
It changes the center of gravity of the
caliphate from the Mediterranean as in
Damascus to um,
uh,
basically to Persia,
India,
the lands between them,
modern Afghanistan, Pakistan,
at least those are as important if not
more so now than the Mediterranean.
Even though the empire stretches
from the Indus River to the Atlantic,
it's center of gravity
has clearly shifted.
This has implications also for culture
as we'll talk about in a moment.
The accomplishment of the opposite
caliphate in terms of culture is to bring
together realms that had not been
okay
in very much contact with each other.
Certainly not in terms of ideas,
namely India,
Persia and the Roman empire
or the former medic. Uh,
empire of the Mediterranean east
purchase stands in the middle
between India and the West.
To the extent that Persia is not
a isolated empire of its own,
but a crossroads.
This means that there's all this
exchange of information, techniques,
science,
art and culture.
But most of all,
the establishment of Baghdad clearly
means a different kind of rulership.
One that it does not break with the
[inaudible] but rather to some extent, um,
uh, elaborates on it. This is an empire.
It is not a kind of sacred
kingdom of people living in tents.
Okay.
This is an empire more
open to eastern influences.
That is to say somewhat more Persian
in its style, less Mediterranean.
Um,
and originally more Shiite.
Yeah.
So the significance of the opposite
takeover is really basically two fold.
One is this move east to
Baghdad with all that,
it symbolizes that I just got through
saying the influence of non Muslim,
uh, non Arab Muslims and the creation of
a complex administration and even more
complex administration than that
of the Mayans. And then two,
it shows the influence of the Shiites.
This begins is a Shiite victory. But uh,
very quickly the Shiites, as
I said, are disillusioned.
And so it also shows the
limitations of the Shiites.
The Shiites don't just want a
non Arab dominated Islamic world.
They want what we called last week,
a Republican administration
on non monarchical polity.
And the opposites are
monarchical if there anything
until the early 10th century when the
opposite Caliphate starts to break up. Uh,
the, uh, uh, world of Islam was splendid,
rich,
cultivated and scientifically,
uh,
progressive.
There would be no more great conquests,
particularly in the West,
all ready before the opposites took power.
We've pointed to two moments in which
the Arab expansion or the Islamic
expansion was stopped.
One in seven,
17 before the walls of Constantinople
in the failed siege of Constantinople to
the battle of Poitier,
not that far from Paris in
northern France in seven 33.
A battle at which the Merovingians
or really their high servants,
um, so called mayors of the
palace defeated Arab Raiders,
um, who then retreated
basically back to Spain.
To some extent,
these defeats in the West.
We're not so much defeats from the Caliphs
point of view as a reorientation in
seven 50.
Moving the capital back to Baghdad.
The capital to Baghdad from Damascus
also means less interest in the west.
Less interest in trying to take over
France if that was ever a serious goal,
less interest in besieging Constantinople.
The opposites begin by inviting all
of the Umayyad survivors to a banquet,
supposed to be a banquet
of reconciliation,
and instead they had their servitors
kill all of the [inaudible] at the dinner
table, spread a leather
cloth over the, um,
some of them were already dead,
some of them merely wounded. Um,
and with the leather cloth over them, a
set the table again and banquet on there,
a dead and dying,
uh,
enemies satisfying. Definitely. Um,
one whom I had escaped,
uh, not from the banquet,
but he had had the foresight
to say he was busy, uh,
and he escaped as far as he could go
in the Muslim world, namely Spain.
The last [inaudible] then,
um,
Abdur Rahman came to Spain
and was a claimed by the
population or got himself to
be a claimed by the population and ruled
in Spain as the first Islamic ruler to
defy the califate.
Thus,
the first independent Islamic kingdom,
we can call it,
although they don't use that term,
the first independent Islamic kingdom
independent of the caliphate would be
Spain.
The Omi had ruler actually
recognized by Dodd.
He did not proclaim
himself arrival caliph.
It was easy for him to recognize Baghdad
3000 miles away or whatever it is.
Uh, they weren't going to come and
get him. He took the title of Emea.
Emi are, uh, a ruler who is,
um, it's more like a title of
a governor than that of a king.
Nevertheless, as I said, um,
Islamic Spain represents the first piece
of the Cali Fall Empire to break off
when the opposite califit ran into
trouble in the early 10th century.
Then the Umayyad ruler of Spain
proclaimed himself college
in nine 29,
he proclaimed himself caliph of Cordoba
Cordova was the capital of [inaudible]
Spain.
And so at this point,
Spain becomes the most splendid,
most cultivated part of the Islamic world.
So if the period of the maximum power and
splendor of the opposite caliphate was
roughly seven 50 to nine,
10,
the period of maximum splendor of the
caliphate of Cordoba in all under loose or
Spain was about eight 52,
it's sudden collapse in 1009.
Okay.
Questions? Problems? A
lot of names here. No,
you don't have a final exam. So what
do you care? But I realize it is,
um, uh, a dramatic story,
but one with a large cast of characters
by now you're used to this in history.
Um,
whether these are good cat names or not,
I'm not as sure as I am with the
barbarians, uh, but worth experiments
as Wickham has described,
the Abbasid Caliphate was based on
tax collection and administration.
And your response to that may
be, uh, yeah, well, so what,
um, but that's not true of all the
states that we've been studying.
If you take something
like mirror eventual goal,
even though in the early period
they're still collecting taxes.
Remember Fred or gun tells chill Peric
let's burn these tax records and maybe
our sons will be cured
of their disease by God.
Uh,
but you'll have seen in Gregory a tour
that basically the mirror of engines are
rich because of plunder,
military expeditions and land land
above all is the source of wealth in the
kingdoms of Western Europe land and the
peasants to till it obviously it's no
good if it's just empty land,
usually not least.
It's productive land and this is
the source of wealth. Therefore,
the state gains its wealth on the basis
of things like land, military power,
and not on the basis of taxing
and economy that is more sluggish,
has less trade,
less income than in the uh,
uh,
cities of the Muslim world.
Okay.
The Caliphate was a tax paying
state with a central army.
Therefore,
the nobility as such as it was,
was not a group of local potentates
as they had been under the late Roman
empire.
Great landowners for example.
Nor was it a military elite cuase I
independent whose loyalty to the ruler was
conditional on their own interest.
As we've seen with the Merovingian,
um, uh, nights rather,
it was a complicated administration
served as a structure of a vast empire and
the tax revenue came into the
college whose administration,
who's civilian administration,
was supreme over army,
over local elites,
over great land owners.
At least for a time.
The opposite empire was the greatest
state in the world at that time.
It's only rival,
might've been Tang China,
but this is the period of the decline
of that empire bogged Dodd was the
wealthiest and largest city in the world.
Okay.
Among the programs of the Abbasids in
addition to building this plan city,
uh, um, creating a certain
kind of military structure,
consolidating their conquest among
their plans was a cultural program.
The cultural flowering of the Abbasid
Caliphate is in part a planned flowering,
not just a spontaneous one.
The Caliphs funded translations into
Arabic of Greek and Persian texts dealing
with science,
geography,
mathematics, philosophy,
and medicine in particular
in eight 30,
one of the columns established in Baghdad,
a kind of combination of library and
Research Institute called the House of
Wisdom.
Okay.
The House of wisdom in the first place,
paid for and sponsored translations,
but it also conducted research activities,
things like an effort to measure
the circumference of the earth.
Okay.
Kind of thing that,
you know,
how do you actually do that
without modern instrumentation?
A lot of the material that they,
um,
translated was from
Greek scientific works.
Where did they get these? In some
cases they got them from Byzantium,
from Constantinople itself.
It said that one treaty between
Constantinople and Baghdad cold for,
among other things,
um,
the Byzantine emperor to lend to Baghdad,
a copy of Ptolemies
geography. Ptolemy, the,
uh, one of the great geographers
of the ancient world,
a author of a book called the
great geography known in the West.
Later on when it was translated into
Latin from the Arabic as the Alma guest,
which is a Arab garb,
Latin garbling of an Arab garbling of
the original Greek title of the work.
So this was known in the West even when
it was translated into Latin as the Alma
guest.
And it was just one of many works that
when they finally reached Western Europe
in translations from the Arabic kept a
kind of version of their Arabic name.
But the idea that as part of a treaty, one
of the things was you lend us this, uh,
uh, copy of Ptolemy so that we can
translate it into Arabic shows,
the commitment of the rulers to the
expansion of practical knowledge.
What Islamic scholars,
scientists and policymakers were most
interested in from the classical world
that is from the world of the Greek
and Roman civilization was science,
broadly speaking, science. They were
less concerned with Greek plays,
Greek poetry,
Greek literature in general.
This is partly because they had their
own poetic tradition in Arabic and partly
because they're real source of inspiration
for literature would be Persia.
Uh, the stories as in
the Arabian Nights, uh,
and the kind of lyrical poetry,
uh,
of the Arabs like love poetry
or sensuous poetry, uh,
is either homegrown or Persian.
Okay.
So they translated things like Euclid on
geometry or the physician Daya score at
ease, uh, who wrote,
not the only,
but the leading pharmaceutical manual,
pharmaceutical manual list of drugs,
their properties, what they come from,
what they can cure.
However,
although they concentrated on science,
they also were interested in philosophy.
They were also interested in propositions.
The Lenten nature of reality,
metaphysics.
And the major project in this realm
was the translation of Aristotle.
Aristotle is someone
who wrote on everything
on drama, poetry, politics,
metaphysics, ethics, animals,
physics.
And so his influence would be tremendous
in all three religions that we are
concerned with, Islam,
Christianity and Judaism.
His influence tends to be interrelated.
Realms are factors.
One is its comprehensiveness.
They didn't translate
everything of Aristotle's,
but all three civilizations were aware
of Aristotle as a universal thinker.
That somewhere in the work of Aristotle,
there's something about
everything that's worth studying.
He has then an encyclopedic thinker
in a way that Plato is not right.
Plato is not interested
in the natural world.
If you go to Plato for information
about animals or plants,
you're going to be out of luck because
Plato despises things like that.
Plato's very interested in ethics
in how to live life in reality,
in the relationship between
matter and spirit. Um,
but he's not a scientist. Um, he, uh, uh,
to put it mildly,
he's not interested in the material world,
whereas Aristotle believes
that the material world,
although not necessarily the be all
and end all of everything is reliable,
that our senses can give
us decent information.
But observation of the natural world
leads to more than merely practical
knowledge, if you know, say how to
plow or how to plant things. Uh,
but leads to knowledge of what
creation, what nature. Uh,
yes. So Aristotle, his encyclopedic,
and he's also rational. This is the
second contribution that Aristotle makes.
Rationality that anything from plays to,
uh,
rocks can be understood in
terms of a logical analysis.
This is fine when it comes to plays
and rocks, but what about metaphysics?
What about the world of religion?
Aristotle has a profound influence here,
again,
not only on Islam but on Judaism and
Christianity because he essentially
encourages a rational view of God.
Now,
Aristotle is himself not much of a theist.
That is to say Aristotle doesn't go on
about God very much and whatever God
there is an Aristotle is not a personal
God to who you would prey on the
assumption or in the belief that he
was interested in your wellbeing.
The closest Aristotle gets to God is
the notion of a kind of great mechanic,
the prime mover as he would be
called in western philosophy.
The guy who makes the mechanism,
sets it going and maybe
every so often maintains it.
Maybe little oil here,
a little bit of timing there,
but he's not the god of Gregory of tour.
He's not the God who is inspiring saints
to get revenge when their powers or
questioned or when somebody
steals. Hey, from there,
this is not Aristotle's God.
Aristotle's God is
not concerned with our
little petty squabbles. Uh,
it's not Mohammed's God exactly either.
A,
it's not a god who
brings victory in battle,
who's interested in a new prophecy that
will seal all the previous profits.
It's a somewhat mechanistic God.
It's an 18th century God.
Even a sort of deist God.
For those of you who have studied
that, the notion, you know, uh,
uh, that, um, uh,
the world must've been created by God
because it has a lot of design in it.
It works. You know, it has a, uh,
one animal gives birth to another
animal just like it. You know,
the tides go in and out. The
weather is usually rational. Uh,
winter is usually cold.
Halloween is usually crisp. Um,
uh, that's imposed by some
kind of original order.
Just like if you went and found
a watch on a deserted pathway,
you wouldn't assume that nature
had constructed the watch,
that it just was growing there,
the way the ferns were growing by the
path you would assume some artificer had
been. But that doesn't mean that
the artifice or is still alive,
still interested in the watch,
uh,
inclined to take care of you.
I go on this detour or seeming detour
about Aristotle because he's important to
everything in the period
that we're discussing.
And also in the period of
that is concerned for the
West in the continuation of
this course in history to 11,
there are three thinkers
just to take examples.
The most famous thinkers
in each of the Jewish,
Christian and Islamic traditions
who embrace Aristotle.
And in doing so, embrace the
idea of as a rational, um,
companion to ma'am,
these are the Arab philosopher
known in the West as a Vero,
as cure.
Again,
as with all my guests were using his
sort of Latin garbled name of fairways
active in Spain,
1126 to 1198.
My monities,
perhaps the greatest Jewish philosopher,
a rabbi,
a physician accordia and a philosopher,
also active in Spain.
Uh, but also in Egypt,
1135 to 1204
and Thomas Aquinas.
Okay.
You spent most of his career
teaching at the University of Paris
1225 to 1274.
All of these thinkers embraced Aristotle,
the Latin ones,
um, uh, like Aquinas, uh,
via translations from the Arabic.
Aristotle was known in the medieval west,
not from the Greek originals,
but from translations made
from Arabic into Latin.
All believed that reason
and faith are compatible
all base, their outlook not
only on nature, but on God,
on an heiress cotillion form of knowledge.
Interesting
in that Aristotle knew
nothing about Judaism,
Christianity or Islam.
Huh?
So what is the,
in about Aristotle,
what is it about dive securities?
What is it about Tommy?
All of these scientists and philosophers
that is of such fascination to the
Islamic world.
All of this emphasis that we've made
on Islamic culture and its openness to
other influences may seem strange to you.
In light of the reputation
Islam has in modern America,
or at least in many circles of modern
America and Europe as being obscure,
ramp test or anti modern or
religiously inflexible. Uh,
I teach, uh, a group of, uh,
retired people in where I
live in just outside New York.
Uh, and we're studying, um,
Islamic Spain and they're like astounded
at w what I've just described at the
openness of Islam to other
civilizations at its tolerance at,
it's a curiosity about
classical and Persian science.
And I was surprised because
this is not new information.
This is not something that historians have
just come up with and just discovered.
If you read medieval history
textbooks of 100 years ago,
it's in there.
Everybody knows that Aristotle was
translated from Arabic into Latin.
Everybody knows everybody who
studied the of the Middle Ages knows.
And I said to them, because you know,
you can't say to older people, oh, well,
you know, your education
is, uh, is uh, uh,
actually not very good.
The way we say to you right all the time
or your attention span is not very good
because all, you know, all,
all you're doing is you're,
you're plugged into uh, uh,
your, uh, your social world. No,
these people went to college and the tough
old days I'd legitly and they're like,
God,
I thought Islam was just,
I thought it was just like this sort of
frozen religion that had never changed.
And so, um, you don't
have that disadvantage.
You don't have that idea.
And so I'm not going to brow beat you
with it on the basis of the experience of
teaching 70 year olds.
Uh, but there it is. Um,
I do not accept the notion well with one
exception, with one honorable exception.
Um, right. Right. Me Too. So,
um,
uh,
I don't want to go into a long
discussion about, you know,
Islam right or wrong or Islam
progressive or regressive.
I will say this.
Uh,
there are those who believe
wrongly in my opinion,
that there's always been this clash of
civilization as it's sometimes called
between the Progressive
Christian West and the, uh,
obscurantist Islamic East.
I don't accept that in part
for reasons you've just heard.
There is no a consistent
Islamic tradition, uh,
of,
um,
of the maintenance of Dogma
or the conversion of the
world by force in so far as
that exists now. Uh, it is, in my opinion,
a modern phenomenon.
It is a phenomenon that results from an
encounter with the West beginning around
the time of Napoleon's conquest of Egypt.
Perhaps it's about two centuries old.
There's another kind of belief
that at some point things changed.
And there's a book by Bernard Lewis,
the most eminent western scholar of
Islamic culture called what went wrong.
And so Louis's assumption is that
the world that I'm describing,
the opposite caliphate is an open society.
And at some point,
and for some reasons, uh, the
Islamic world closed itself,
became less susceptible to outside
influence, more suspicious of it,
more dogmatic,
more anti modern,
more fixated on literalism what in the
West during the question traditionally be
called fundamentalism. Uh,
and, uh, on, uh, tradition.
Uh,
I don't really like this either because
it sees all progress as the property of
Western civilization.
Uh,
and it's not that I am not
interested in western civilization.
I've taught it, I taught
it because I liked it. Uh,
I'm not somebody who, you
know, uh, believes that it's
all a tale of oppression.
Uh,
but I don't think that anybody who diverts
from the path of Western civilization
at some point is, you know, um, uh,
going off the cliff or off
the trail and into the woods,
there are a lot of different
civilizations out there.
There's a third related idea that the
Arabs are just intermediaries. Yeah,
it's great.
They translate Aristotle so that the
real guys who can really use Aristotle,
Thomas Aquinas, that all
can, can get started.
And I don't accept that either because,
uh, uh, they do more than that.
They do an awful lot of original
research and medicine in mathematics,
in philosophy.
But within all of this, to my
mind, fruitless speculation,
there is a kernel of what
is an interesting problem.
And the interesting problem is why were
the Arabs so much more successful in
assimilating conquered cultures
than other invaders were?
Say for example,
the Germans,
you don't get this kind of a efflorescence
of culture under the barbarian
occupants of the former Roman empire.
We're talking not just about
cultural survival, keep in mind,
but about uh, um, a,
an expansion of science and uh,
allied arts.
I'd say there are maybe four factors that
encourage the Arab conquest to absorb
these new influences and they're
not in themselves explanations,
but they're certainly background factors.
The fact that the conquest was
quick and relatively painless
and then it was not
really a religious war.
Two and I think here,
very important,
the elimination of frontiers.
I mentioned this briefly before,
you get Persian as well as
Greek astronomy from India.
You get things like chess,
so-called Arabic numerals,
[inaudible] we all know come from India.
These come into the Arab and Persian
worlds from India and eventually to Europe
as well.
In a world in which there are no
frontiers between India and uh,
North Africa, you can go, uh,
these thousands of miles peacefully.
The elimination of linguistic boundaries,
Arab [inaudible],
the language of learning
much as Latin would be, uh,
in the European Middle Ages,
much as English has tended
to become in our era.
Okay.
So my monities, the great Jewish
philosopher wrote largely in Arabic,
the Christians of Spain, so
called Mozarabic Christians, uh,
studied Arabic, fought in
Arabic, wrote in Arabic.
And finally,
number four,
the attitude of the conquerors and the
conquered the attitude of the conquerors
was, um, what Peter Brown and
the reading for Wednesday,
we'll call a garden
protected by our spirit.
Since this is a quote
from one of the concours,
the Arab concours considered these to be
wonderful civilizations that they were
not going to pillage or destroy,
but rather protect a garden
protected by our spears.
But they were planning
on enjoying the garden,
not merely standing on the outside
defending it for other people to enjoy
the conquerors. We're confident
in their religion, so confident,
but they didn't need for others
to recognize it or convert.
It also gave them the confidence to
accept new ideas from Greek civilization,
from Persian civilization,
from India.
But there's also the
attitude of the conquered.
Brown says that as the storm of the
Arab armies rolled over the horizon,
the population of the Near East
sat back to enjoy the sunshine.
The Islamic conquest was of benefit and
perceived as of benefit by most of the
people who were conquered.
A kind of counter example
in a way explains this.
In Cordova, the Capitol of
the Umayyad Caliphate of uh,
or soon to be colorful of um, uh, Spain.
A group of Christians around
eight 50 were so upset at the,
um,
contented attitude of the Christians
of Islamic Spain who were,
if not a majority, probably about
50%, close to 50% of this time,
these more fanatical,
or at least more serious Christians were
so angry that all of their compatriots
seem to be just fine with Islamic rule.
That they got up in the marketplace
of Cordova and denounced Mohammed as a
charlatan,
as a false god,
and as not a prophet.
And while Islam is tolerant,
that is something that you couldn't
do a, so they did, you know,
the thing that was most
defiant of the regime,
really the moral equivalent of like
burning yourself, uh, in the marketplace.
And indeed they were imprisoned, told
to recant. And when they didn't recant,
they were executed.
Uh,
there are about 50 of these martyrs
of Cordova as they're called,
but they have to seek martyrdom
because they have to look for it.
They have to create it because almost
all the rest of their compatriots are
perfectly happy to be most Arabic
Christians practicing the freedom of their
religion under a beneficence regime,
beneficence in the eyes of these martyr
Christians. But nevertheless, uh, uh,
you know, uh, the, uh,
a regime of the devil.
This shows you something about the nature
of the Arab conquest and occupation.
Uh,
let me just speak briefly about
a couple of aspects of what the,
uh, Islamic world was
interested in studying. Uh,
and we may continue over into next time,
uh,
since the lecture on the seventh
centuries actually rather short. Uh,
let's start with mathematics.
The great accomplishment of this time
is the introduction of Arabic numbers,
which if you've ever tried to multiply
or divide with Roman numerals are
superior Arabic numbers come from India.
And along with this system of numerals,
they imported zero,
both of the number or the
non number and the concept,
the concept of zero allows for
things like decimal places,
which are also developed at this time
from India.
The Arabs get the kind of very
basic ideas of trigonometry,
the sine function,
but it is their own researches,
their own progress that leads to the
call it discovery or development of the
five other functions.
And here I'm on kind of tricky ground
because despite what they tell you about
math literacy and how important it is,
I haven't used this since 10th grade,
but I do remember the co-sign,
the tangent,
the Cotangent, the sea
Canton, the Cosi camp, right?
All of these are discovered by the Arabs.
Hey, they are, they built on an edifice,
uh,
whose foundation is Indian mathematics
in the early ninth century,
a scholar attached to that house of
wisdom in Baghdad named all a quorum.
Zane inquiries me around there.
Okay.
Quarries mean in the early ninth century,
Alcor reads me,
writes a book with the title that can
be translated as something like the book
of addition and subtraction
according to the Hindu calculation.
And this is what it incorporates,
zero and decimal places.
And interestingly enough,
this book is known only from
its translation into Latin.
The Latin version survives where's
the original Arabic does not.
Yeah.
Within a century of the
publication of this book,
a decimal fractions had been developed.
Square roots.
The value of Pi to 16 decimal
places had been calculated
at quarries. Me is also the
author of a treatise on Algebra.
The word Algebra comes from Al Jabbar,
uh,
which is sort of restoring,
restoring something that has been in
balance and that you're now going to
balance with of courses in a way,
the visual nature of Algebra
all Cory's me,
it was also an astronomer.
He developed star tables that allowed
one to locate the planets and stars at
different times of year
and at different latitudes.
This is what allows the making of
things like astrolabs or later sexton's.
These are things that describe the sky
at a particular time that allow you then
to keep time and also, um, to navigate,
okay.
To calculate time for things
like prayers or feasts,
celebrations,
also to cast horoscopes.
I'll work a little more with you
on geography, medicine, and then,
um, summer runs the Abbasids at the
beginning of our next class. Uh,
so I'll let you go for now.
Thanks.